we do have a Wonder Liang after a crazy
French game I wonder I was bashing the
French but you decided to go with it how
would you come up with that idea yeah
it's probably like the riskiest opening
I've played this event
um for about the Petrov with Knight
takes C4 yeah the French is worse but
um
but yeah I just wanted
um
to sort of stray away from what I've
played before in this event
um because Rey's kind of an expert in
the Berlin and all these e45 lines
um so yeah I thought definitely it
surprised him a little bit and yeah I
think we kind of just got a regular
position I I feel he's probably trying
to avoid some of my preparation and yeah
for the most part he kind of succeeded
but I was pretty happy with my position
in in this game at least and you were
also up on time quite a lot one hour and
29 minutes and he was dropping down to
his last 40 minutes at this point yeah I
think he he probably was just trying to
remember what
his preparation was and yeah he told me
after the game he was calculating I
think B3 here after rookie one which
yeah no I think um on the previous move
um instead of uh instead of recording
yeah sorry B3 or B4 yeah then takes
takes
and like Bishop A4 Knight A5
and Bishop takes D1 Rook B6
and he has this
um after like we take everything he has
this Knight G5 at the end
um
yeah which like I missed because okay I
was just walking around um I wasn't
actually sure what he was thinking about
but normally in these types of positions
like
it's kind of hard to mess up the move
whereas black I mean you can play like
H6 Queen C7 97 in almost any order
um so I was like from my perspective I
was not too concerned about comfortable
obviously there was like some hidden
dangers in this position
um but yeah I think he probably was just
trying to
yeah sometimes it can be a little
confusing these lines and this was quite
funny because you started with this
Knight's position yes and then like
seven moves later you're in the same
nice position yeah yeah he definitely
missed this Knight G6 and H5 which was
just very powerful
um and yeah I thought yeah it was
definitely very funny that he sort of
just read his Knights went in a circle
um but
but yeah I mean it was kind of difficult
for me to find a way to exploit sort of
his waste of time and sort of the issue
is like his position is still
structurally very solid like okay he
um he has like a lot of weaknesses but
um it's such a close position that I
thought he can probably just build a
fortress
um and I think in the game probably I
could have just kept the Queens on maybe
instead of Queen takes
um I should play Bishop takes
and then like Queen D2 Queen d8
um Knight G5 Bishop takes
um he has to take HG
and then
yeah but like it's it's a little
difficult to see like how I'm gonna
press here I thought like probably I
have to play like B5 A5 at some point
and then bring the Knight to C6
um weak as well yeah and also like I
thought he can just reroute his Bishop
to D2 and just kind of build a fortress
like that
um it's
yeah I mean I have like all the time in
the world but also like it's it's such a
closed position that it's hard hard to
really make progress
um yeah and in the game like okay I
thought this was a very impressive
position
um but but yeah I sort of realized like
okay there's not that much to do after
this
um and yeah I was kind of worried that
I'd probably blender something later in
the game so okay I thought like let's
just end it make a draw I wonder a good
event for you so far how do you assess
your performance yeah I think it's been
more or less normal
um I had sort of a crazy first half with
three decisive games and then okay now
I've made like six draws in a row so
um yeah more or less coming down
um
yeah I think I've played very solid I
sort of went into this event with kind
of a plan about how I wanted to approach
um certain games and I think for the
most part um it's been pretty successful
there's been some games where
I've sort of wanted to stay more solid
as white
and I unexpectedly got some chances like
against shankland I think I had
um sort of this incredible chance in the
opening but that was one game where I
had like work to do in the evening so I
just had to make a quick draw so now
like okay there's been some
sort of issues I think but for the most
part it's been
kind of according to plan and yeah I've
been pretty happy with how it's gone I
wonder we'll be seeing you in the next
two rounds hopefully yes
uh yeah congratulations I wonder it's
been a very nice tournament for you and
uh undefeated uh good luck in the
remaining